madame monsieur bonsoir
voici les titres que nous allons
développer dans ce journal ça c'est du
kosovo des dizaines de milliers
d'albanais arrive au poste frontière
selon le gouvernement britannique un
million de réfugiés ou de déplacés
depuis un mois la moitié aurait quitté
le kosovo ces deux mc arrivera en france
le premier groupe de 308 fusion
lendemains de crise après la démission
surprise de philippe séguin à une
démission qui relancent l'idée de
l'union à droite on attend la réponse de
l'udf à pau dix mille manifestants pour
protester contre les suppressions
d'emplois chez elle une région mobilisés
aux côtés de ses élus l'exode 200 fin de
ces milliers de réfugiés qui continuent
de fuir le kosovo rien que pour cette
journée de samedi
on estime que près de 15000 personnes
vous pourrez avoir franchi le poste
frontière de morina dans le nord de
l'albanie ce point de passage désormais
ouverts 24 heures sur 24 pour absorber
le flot de ces familles qui arrivent à
bout de force il ne faudrait pas
s'habituer à ces images and mentionné
philippe jasmin nul ne saura nous dire
comment cette femme aux cheveux gris
coiffée d'un foulard brun est morte sur
le chemin de l'exil
ceux qui ont terminé le voyage avec son
enfant ne savent même pas qui elle était
des gens nous ont remis cette savant
chemin
on ne sait pas si elle était déjà morte
on n'a pas voulu abandonner le canada
sur la route
absurde et démesurée l'exode s'est
poursuivi hier un rythme plus soutenu
que les jours précédents mais là on
poste frontière des foules venues de
tout le kosovo et par tous les moyens
contre acteurs à pied et en voiture
beaucoup de voitures alors qu'il en
pensait que ces derniers jours dans une
remorque deux hommes blessés affirme
avoir été touché par des éclats d'obus
de bombardements yougoslave
ils ont été blessés par mettant à l'eau
il y a trois semaines
c'est apparemment la ville de mitrovica
et 13 ans donnait au nord de plus l'un
qui est en train de se vider
on était dix villages et rassembler et à
les 9 10 11 cm et pendant toute la route
ils nous ont escorté les jeunes ont été
arrêtés il ya non je n'ai vu aucune
arrestation
selon le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
les témoignages sont les seuls éléments
qui permettent de prévoir les arrivées
de kosovars à maureen une arithmétique
un snack 15 heures c'est tout mitrovica
qui est expulsé et c'était nul initial
manque de 60 70 mille personnes donc
quand on est reçu à peu près 24 en
tuiles ont pu attendre que le reste
arrive puisque gens nous disent il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de gens sur les routes
c'est clair ces nouvelles à plus se
produise dans une vie déjà saturé en
terme d'hébergement là encore les
chiffres sont éloquents à cuq est
quarante deux mille personnes sont
hébergées dans des familles 28000 dans
des centres collectifs 12000 sous tente
dans des camps et 15000 reste depuis
plus de deux semaines sur ce genre de
parking et vivent dans leur remorque
bâchée en macédoine maintenant près de
8000 personnes supplémentaires depuis
hier sont venus grossir le flot des
réfugiés
une équipe de la sécurité civile
française est arrivée à skopje pour
assurer temporairement la gestion d'un
des plus grands camps de macédoine
venant ainsi soulager ce pays qui est de
plus en plus de difficultés à supporter
le poids de l'exil des kosovars qu'avec
brusini crilly plus
ils auront mis un jour et demi pour
parcourir moins de 400 kilomètres et 28
véhicules de la sécurité civile du sud
de la france viennent de tirana après
les uns carrossable route albanaise ils
sont restés bloqués toute la nuit à la
frontière macédonienne
ici la bureaucratie et tatillonne pour
les militaires du camp de stankovic
c'est donc l'heure de la relève l'action
humanitaire française poursuit cette
fois avec des civils à la satisfaction
des réfugiés il redoutait une prise de
contrôle par les macédoniens les
réfugiés toujours plus nombreux la
déportation des kosovars semble
s'accélérer 7 milles en 24 heures sont
arrivés autour de skopje tout le monde
s'enfuit dit cet homme
les serbes ont tué beaucoup de gens et
ils affirment l'avoir vu de ses yeux
auch et vatché coach annick deux cités
qui totalisent 70 mille habitants se
vide en ce moment mais la macédoine
semble incapable d'accueillir davantage
de réfugiés
il est clair que les macédoniens et ils
ont raison sur ce point considère que le
treuil critique est pratiquement atteint
les camps sont plaints des clans et les
familles d'accueil ont fait également le
plein donc il faut trouver l'alternative
il faut trouver d'autres solutions
l'alternative pourrait être
l'organisation d'un corridor humanitaire
entre la macédoine et l'albanie
beaucoup de pays de l'alliance y
travaille avec l'assentiment bien sûr du
gouvernement de skopje pas que je te
promets que vous jouez plus que jamais
nous avons besoin d'un accueil des
réfugiés par d'autres pays cette
situation continue
moi je vous serions particulièrement
soulagé par l'organisation d'un corridor
vers l'albanie et cela jusqu'à ce que
fini de cette situation de guerre
une situation qui perdure aujourd'hui à
la douane côté serbe on voulait
absolument voir les papiers d'identité
des réfugiés même si chaque douaniers
sait bien que tous ces gens se sont vus
retirer leurs passeports
je vous propose maintenant de retrouver
de belgrade notre confrère renaud girard
journaliste au figaro qui est arrivé
hier du kosovo je lui ai demandé en fin
d'après-midi ce qu'il avait constaté
lors de ces deux jours de reportage à
l'intérieur de cette province
du moins pour ce qu'il avait pu en voir
où nous avons parcouru la province d'est
en ouest sur 300 km et partout c'était
un spectacle de désolation
on avait l'impression d'un territoire
pratiquement vidée de sa population
tout autour les villages albanais brûler
y avait même des mosquées détruites pas
tout mais environ 40% la ville de
prizren teitel historique
du kosovo étaient pratiquement désertes
certain tact à part le monument à la
ligue de prizren le monument le
mouvement national 19e siècle qui avait
été dynamitée mais sinon un tas que j'ai
croisés à l'hôpital un médecin serbe et
je lui dis alors la ville est vide
il m'a répondu oui elle est vide cette
guerre est terrible pour les deux
communautés partout nous avons vu des
villages albanais qui était donc vidées
de leur population par les thorne les
forces serbes qui a ensuite été détruit
et également les destructions des bombes
de l'otan dans la ville de del année non
seulement la caserne avait été détruite
mais toute la gare routière avait été
rasé avec une vingtaine de carcasses de
bus carbonisé dans un petit village nous
avons croisé un groupe de 250 personnes
serrés les uns contre les autres les
femmes et les enfants devant au visage
terrorisé qui sans doute attendait un
bus qui devait les emmener j'imagine en
macédoine ou en albanie depuis le début
de l'exode des kosovars des témoignages
donc de plus en plus nombreux font état
d'exactions commises par les serbes à
tirana en albanie
une équipe de la bbc qui tournait un
reportage sur ces familles qui ont fui
se sont vus remettre un document filmé
par un vidéo amateur ce document a été
diffusé hier sur la chaîne britannique
une nouvelle fois difficile de vérifier
l'origine précise des images et les
informations des images qui sont parfois
être difficile à regarder france un
corner
ces réfugiés kosovars regroupés dans le
palais des sports de tirana en albanie
viennent du village de klina près de pec
dans l'ouest du kosovo
ils ont été chassés distille par des
soldats serbes
derrière ces visages fermés tous les
drames qu'ils ont vécu toutes les
horreurs dont ils sont été témoin les
mêmes témoignages recueillis par
l'équipe de la bbc qui font état
d'atrocités commises par les militaires
les policiers où la milice serbe
ils nous ont forcé à partir en albanie
17 femmes nous on voulait rester chez
nous ils nous ont jeté des grenades et
ont tué deux de mes filles
une avait 15 ans l'autre vite je les
enterrait là bas de mes mains ils ont
blessé mon petit à l'épaule et moi à
l'oeil
dieu seul maintenant peut nous sauver
c'est ce qu'on espère dieu et l'otan
c'est très dur pour nous ils ont brûlé
nos maisons et nos maris sont partis
dans les montagnes avec les maquisards
moi je suis seule avec mes enfants
au milieu de se réfugier un homme jeune
temps une cassette vidéo au reporter de
la bbc
les images qu'elle contient sont
terribles l'homme dit avoir filmé lui
même ces images elles sont datées du 27
mars dernier trois jours après le début
des frappes de l'otan
les hommes allongés sur le sol
appartiendraient à la même famille il
aurait été tué dans cette maison après
avoir refusé de partir pendant les
exécutions les femmes et des enfants
étaient cachés à l'étagé au dessus
l'auteur de ces images dit être le
voisin de cette famille est bien la
connaître
je suis arrivé dans la maison et j'ai vu
les citadins ses films et j'ai fait ça
pour que le monde sache nous sont les
serbes
toujours selon cet homme la famille
restée cachée dans la maison près des
corps pendant trois jours trop effrayés
pour sortir et enterrer ses morts
un document qui ne constitue pas
toutefois une preuve irréfutable dans la
mesure où l'authenticité de ces images
est pour l'instant invérifiables et
cette journée de samedi aura été marquée
par de nouvelles déclarations tendant à
prouver l'existence de violence des
assassinats commis par les serbes au
kosovo aux déclarations faites par le
ministre allemand de la défense rudolf
scharping qui évoque de nombreuses
preuves de meurtre effrayant dit il à
bruxelles le porte parole de l'otan a
estimé que près de trois mille deux
cents albanais aurait été assassiné au
cours de ces trois dernières semaines
ces chiffres sont vraisemblables
crédible dit-il ajoutant que des
photographies aériennes montrent ce qui
pourrait être un charnier la terre
retournée récemment ferait croire à un
alignement de tombes
autant d'hypothèses qui reste bien sûr à
vérifier et à bruxelles nous rejoignant
patrice romedenne à l'évidence les
responsables de l'auteur se dit
extrêmement inquiet concernant le sort
des populations qui sont restés au
kosovo
oui béatrice c'est le problème est de
savoir comment leur venir en aide alors
trois possibilités la première c'est un
parachutage de vivres
deux problèmes cependant si les avions
volent à basse altitude et bien ils
s'exposent aux missiles portatifs et à
l'adc acerbes qui comment dirais-je à
l'adc acerbes ou en tout cas ce qu'il en
reste
soit les avions volent à haute altitude
et dans ce cas le parachutage n'est pas
très précis et pourrait tomber chez les
ca mais il ne revient pas franchement à
l'otan d'alimenter les troupes serbes
dit on ici
deuxième possibilité ouvrir un corridor
humanitaire à l'intérieur même du kosovo
l'otan reconnaît qu'elle étudie la
faisabilité d'une telle action en ce
moment mais cela nécessite d'envoyer des
hommes au sol
troisième possibilité aider les
organisations non gouvernementales il en
a déjà trois sur place ce sont des ong
grecs auxquels pourraient se joindre des
ong appartenant à des pays neutres dans
ce conflit c'est cette troisième
possibilité qui semble avoir la
préférence de l'eau tant qu'animal souci
humanitaire certes mais aussi un souci
militaire car le fait que des centaines
de milliers de personnes un peu
éparpillée partout au kosovo r sur les
routes du kosovo ne favorise pas ne
facilite pas pardon les opérations
militaires l'otan le reconnaît et on l'a
vu récemment avec cette fameuse bavure
il ya trois jours dont on a beaucoup
parlé
merci patrice romedenne le commandant
suprême de l'otan en europe le général
wesley clark s'est rendu en macédoine et
en albanie aujourd'hui déclarant que les
forces alliées allait détruire tout ce à
quoi milosevic attache du prix pendant
ce temps-là belgrade se dérouler des
mariages collectifs et amarat en
réunissant plus de dix mille personnes
richard binet ce matin plusieurs avions
de l'otan sont rentrés à leur base
chargé de leurs bombes
ils ont dû rebrousser chemin le mauvais
temps ne leur permettaient pas
d'atteindre les cibles qui leur étaient
assignées durant la nuit des forces
alliées ont concentré leur fera que deux
objectifs
lusine de valjevo à 80 km au sud ouest
de belgrade déjà pratiquement détruite
ainsi que le complexe industriel de
viser au centre de la serbie
une nuit calme en quelque sorte même si
quelques heures plus tard le ministre de
la défense britannique démontrait carte
à l'appui que les systèmes de
communication avait été fortement
endommagé il était difficile pour
belgrade de savoir quelles cibles
avaient été touchés nous allons encore
identifiés n'aurait quant à la question
de savoir combien de temps ils dureront
soyez sûr que nous serons présents aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra cet après-midi
le général clark commandant suprême de
l'otan en europe étaient reçus à tirana
après avoir confirmé la capture d'un
officier serbe par lui ces cas il
condamnait les incursions yougoslave en
albanie sans toutefois préciser si les
forces de l'otan était prête à sécuriser
la frontière
ces raids sont absolument inacceptables
c'est une violation flagrante d'un
territoire souverain ils doivent être
stoppées et milosevic doit cesser ses
agressions ce square la télévision
d'hugo slave consacré les dernières
images de son journal au 12e marathon de
belgrade
dix mille athlètes défiant les bombes de
l'otan puis c'est autre image celle
rassurante d'un mariage collectif
dix neuf couples unis c'est leur destin
dans l'ancien palais royal comme aux
plus belles heures de la serbie impérial
à tirana dans la capitale albanaise
continuent d'arriver les soldats des
forces alliées une cohabitation pour ces
centaines d'hommes basés sur l'aéroport
mais bien sûr répartis dans différentes
unités au périlleux de l'air et patrick
voir ont pu suivre l'installation des
troupes américaines
l'otan sur le terrain ce ca des
relations de bon voisinage mais pas de
mélange en face du camp français 350
hommes sont aujourd'hui basés à tirana
les américains continuent d'arriver
officiellement ils sont 500
principalement venue des bases aériennes
d'allemagne ont dit qu'ils pourraient
être bientôt plus de 1000 difficiles à
vérifier
on le sait le soldat n'est pas bavard
mais quand il est américain il peut
devenir franchement cachottier quel va
être votre mission ici j'en sais rien il
nous présentera à décider mais vous
pensez que vous allez devoir vous battre
j'espère que non on n'est pas venu pour
se battre je préférais aider les gens
que de me parle
en attendant d'en savoir plus le soldat
américain s'installe au mieux leur home
sweet home ces fonds pour la morale et
pendant que le français patauge un peu
dans la boue son collègue
d'outre-atlantique magnifie l'art de la
logistique
chargé comme tous les alliés d'acheminer
l'aide humanitaire vers le nord de
l'albanie
les américains pour 18 sorties par jour
la moitié de celles réalisées par les
français la sécurité l'obsession du
pentagone et toute annonce d'accrochages
dans la zone frontalière tous les
appareils au sol
aucune information en revanche sur les
hélicoptères apache offrait de l'armée
de terre américaine
retranché à l'autre bout de l'aéroport
le mot d'ordre est humanitaire et la
langue de bois
ne pensez-vous pas que 1200 hommes c'est
trop de l'humanitaire et pas assez pour
une opération militaire
je vous répète qu'il n'y a pour
l'instant que 5 cents américains sont
sept aéroports
leur seul but est d'aider au
ravitaillement des réfugiés français
américains ou en tout cas en commun
d'attendre des nouvelles de bruxelles
c'est l'otan qui décidera dans les jours
qui viennent d'une réalisation conjointe
ou non de la mission allier sur le
terrain demain la france devrait
accueillir un premier groupe de réfugiés
308 albanais venant de macédoine vont
atterrir dans la journée de dimanche à
lyon
voici comment ces volontaires ont été
choisis et comment elles se préparent au
départ valérie fournier ou frédéric
basket dès l'aube ils ont attendu
plusieurs heures sous la pluie comme
stand
ils ont cherché longtemps dans le camp
la file d'attenté à destination de la
france
tu dis on annonce officiellement la
maintenant la liste des gens qui partent
pour la france une annonce enfin
officiel et les noms vont être
méticuleusement articulé pour qu'il n'y
ait aucune confusion
j'amène attendre à 15 minutes avant que
le nom shabani soit prononcé presque ko
debout de contentement lady nom de sa
famille sont bien sur la liste on
s'épuise
la destination france était un espoir
pour eux mais même les partants ne sont
pas forcément comblé
sa femme n'a pas là il est inquiet de
partir pour la france sans sa femme du
compliqué de partir pour la france que
partir pour l'allemagne ou une autre
destination
oui c'était plus compliqué parce que je
crois que dans la france les conditions
sont meilleures on est à accueillir chez
dc des familles de ceux qui partent en
allemagne il change de camp ça c'est
rien de tour la liste vers la france a
été en partie établie par le responsable
de télécoms sans frontières
mandaté par l'ambassade de france on est
en masse humaine dans cette boue que
vous voyez à trois kilomètres du but
serbe
on est là avec eux et l'ambassade de
fait un travail merveilleux et et nous a
permis de participer nous aussi à la
composition de cet avion à destination
donc de la france
la france est donc resté fidèle à sa
politique du maintien des réfugiés des
coûts souvent dans la région
car demain matin les trois avions qui
partent pour la france nous marquerons
que 307 personnes 307 sur les milliers
qui rêvent de quitter les camps repris
en main progressivement par les
autorités macédoniennes dont les troupes
sont à majorité serbe et ses réfugiés
albanais seront hébergés dans différents
foyers d'accueil en france pour
l'instant ils ne seraient pas prises en
charge par des familles qui se sont
portés volontaires
ils ont besoin de conserver leur
environnement virginie fichet et olivier
jacquelin ont assisté aux derniers
préparatifs dans ses foyers qui en
général accueille des immigrés au bout
de l'escalier il y a le huitième palier
celui attribué à la trentaine de
réfugiés qui arrivera ici demain
derrière les portes
le décor de leur nouvel exil donc là on
retrouve dans un détail et qu'on a ré
ouvert spécialement pour laquelle de
cette population
nous avons trente chambres toutes faites
de façon à qui font sept mètres carrés
avec un petit coin de douala
le reste est collectif à lyon 8 foyers
semblable à celui ci accueilleront dès
demain 300 vies réfugiés kosovars venus
du camp de ce thème covec en macédoine
pour le moment le rez de chaussée du
foyer fourmille chargé de leur
hébergement le comité rhodanien
d'accueil des réfugiés et de défense du
droit d'asile le trr d'un met la
dernière main aux préparatifs dégager
autant de sur la composition exacte du
groupe
l'association navigue encore à vue seule
indication beaucoup d'enfants de moins
de cinq ans se trouverait parmi les
réfugiés
en plus d'un toit il a donc fallu
prévoir le minimum vital
il ya de la nourriture pour trois jours
fagg les premiers première chose de
nécessiter un ski et nourriture ce qui
est produits d'entretien sera distribué
dès leur arrivée huit interprètes des
médecins des psychologues
ici les réfugiés seront entourée
d'attentions un encadrement souple pour
d'abord leur réapprendre à vivre
normalement
ce qui est urgent c'est de les rendre
indépendants et non pas des poudres
c'est ça qui est urgent pour les
restituer en dignité pour aller à la
pharmacie au supermarché à la salle de
bain quand il en rit oui c'est pas
d'avoir trop d'attention c'est d'être
respectés clé de cette dignité retrouvée
une autorisation provisoire de séjour de
trois mois et une allocation 35 francs
par jour pour un adulte 24 ans pour un
enfant de quoi gérer une autonomie à
réinventer et concernant ses premiers
réfugiés albanais du kosovo voici ce
qu'a déclaré lionel jospin ce matin il
confirme que les réfugiés pourront être
accueillis dans des familles des quotas
c'est une goutte d'eau qui a beaucoup de
sens je crois
et puis c'est peut-être une première
goutte d'eau n'oubliez pas ce que j'ai
dit nous voulons agir là bas traités là
bas et accueillir ici
nous allons rester conforme à cette
philosophie dans notre parti vous
l'avons fait naturellement en étroite
relation avec le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés en répondant à ces critères
puisque c'est lui qui a vocation au nom
des nations unies à traiter ces
problèmes de personnes déplacées ils
devraient être accueillis dans une
structure collective de façon à ce qu'on
puisse parler avec eux regarder l'état
de santé certains d'entre eux et c'est
ensuite que à la demande des familles
françaises qui le souhaiteront ils
pourront être accueillis de façon plus
humaine plus affective dans des cellules
familiales dans notre pays
comme chaque semaine depuis le début du
conflit le baromètre de l'opinion
publique française avec eux ce sondage
ipsos le journal du dimanche le camp des
sceptiques se renforce puisque 52% des
français estiment que cette intervention
est en passe d'échouer
ils n'étaient que 29 % à avoir ce
sentiment la semaine dernière 33 %
considèrent que les opérations de l'otan
sont en train de réussir deuxième
question concernant l'adhésion aux
frappes de l'alliance une adhésion
toujours très soutenue avec que 70% qui
approuve 26 % désapprouvent
enfin 64% des français sont toujours
pour une intervention terrestre 30 %
sont contre voici pour ce dossier
concernant donc le conflit en
yougoslavie
et puis cette information qui nous
parviendra l'instante de londres 13
personnes dont un policier ont été
blessés dans un quartier populaire au
sud de londres à l'extérieur d'un
supermarché à brixton précisément aucune
alerte à la bombe n'avait été donnée en
algérie après l'élection d'abdelaziz
bouteflika à la grande majorité de la
presse juste ce scrutin sans gloire et
sans panache manifestation hier âgées
mais aussi en kabylie où plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont protesté
contre cette élection boycottée par les
six autres candidats
reportage en kabylie dans cette région
qui s'est massivement abstenus de voter
gérard griesbeck et bruno girodon à tizi
ouzou
nous sommes dans l'autre algérie
l'algérie rebelles l'algérie qui
conteste l'algérie des kabyles de ceux
qui vivaient là avant l'arrivée des
arabes et qui entendent garder leur
culture et leur langue à tizi ouzou où
on cherche en vain des électeurs
d'abdelaziz bouteflika ou même des
électeurs tout court on était là on a vu
il y avait personne qui a limité
il y avait personne qui avait vanté
d'aller voir à michel dans certaines
régions il y avait des votants si vous
vous croyez au père noël
moi je n'y crois pas donc pour moi mans
n'ont pas eu lieu ces élections
actuelles il ya eu des fraudes dès le
départ c'est et c'était prévu le voit
ici les gens soutiennent surtout le ffs
d'hocine aït tahar med qui s'est retiré
à la veille des élections tout le rcd
qui a appelé au boycottage devant
l'université où les affrontements avec
le pouvoir ont toujours été très dur
les gens ne sont pas tendres avec le
président élu président pour moi c'est
un homme a mac à partir pour faire le
combat donnant même
ci comprendra pas encore lu zhengwei
camp de l'autre président parce que il y
avait la fraude
c'est cette fois c'est aussi prendre
connais pas beaucoup leur a quand même
un président on ne reconnaît pas il
n'est pas démocrate la kabylie sont
opposés à la dictature elle s'est
opposée au colonialisme se posera donc
la kabylie est fondamentalement
démocratique alors que les fraudes ont
laissé beaucoup d'algériens désabusé
voire indifférents en kabylie en
revanche les rassemblement d'hier ont
encore montré le refus de tout retour au
passé politique française avec ce
lendemain de crise après la démission de
philippe séguin à une démission qui
pourrait ouvrir la voie à une union à
droite pour les européennes c'est le
voeu de nicolas sarkozy qui assure
désormais la présidence du rpr par
intérim
reste à connaître la réponse de l'idf
jeff wittenberg françois granier ce que
vous avez un commentaire à faire
non non à soi bayrou ne dira rien
aujourd'hui mais le président de l'udf
ne boude pas son plaisir de sa décision
il le sait des ponts la façon dont la
droite va se présenter aux européennes
car au rpr la page est donc tournée avec
l'entrée en scène de nicolas sarkozy
derrière la personne et la politique du
président de la république jacques
chirac à sa droite le président du sénat
christian poncelet l'un de ceux qui avec
alain juppé jean louis debré josselin de
rohan et s'il le veut philippe séguin
composent la direction provisoire du
mouvement c'était la décision la plus
urgents mais pour les européennes aussi
une bas donc falloir aller vite à
seulement deux mois du scrutin
jusque là il y avait la liste sega
madelin et la liste bayrou c'est qu'un
parti le rpr propose une nouvelle offre
le message du rpr est simple si chances
d'une liste d'union
il ya tout doit être fait pour conduire
cette chance jusqu'à son terme la
perspective d'une liste unique est
pourtant loin d'être acquise car l'udf
précisément avait choisi il ya quelques
semaines de partir seul à la bataille
des européennes derrière françois bayrou
du coup aujourd'hui et centristes ne
sont guère enthousiastes à l'idée de
revenir en arrière
nous ne sommes pas les pompiers de
l'opposition lance françois léotard il y
aura de toute façon des conditions
l'unef ne renoncera certainement pas à
ses exigences et à ses convictions
européennes en aucun cas et à aucun prix
valéry giscard d'estaing que
quelques-uns à droite verrait bien
diriger une liste unique n'a rien dit ce
matin de ses intentions ou rpr d'autres
noms circulent ceux d'edouard balladur
de michel barnier ou de nicolas sarkozy
lui-même
le temps presse tout le monde à droite
est au moins d'accord là dessus
partant à présent pour epinal le fief de
philippe séguin il député des vosges
depuis 1978 fut longtemps le maire de la
ville
voici les réactions des militants mais
aussi de ceux qu'il a côtoyés pendant 14
ans à la mairie
kristin booth patrick sous enchère alors
vous voyez on mange tous main dans celle
là c'est comme dans le cochon tout est
bon pour gilbert le maraîcher comme pour
les 40000 habitants d'epinal la
démission de philippe séguin est une
lointaine affaire de rivalité
d'ambitions politiques qui leur échappe
ou les indiffère non mais il voyait
peut-être président de la république
et puis bon il ya beaucoup de déception
je connais comme ça mais c'est tout il
viendra peut-être un peu plus et epinal
c'est ainsi que l'on se consolent
également à la permanence de philippe
séguin député des vosges
oui non on n'a aucune nouvelle de lui
passé le choc de l'annoncé fidèles
militants comprennent t approuve sa
démission spectaculaire sans mâcher
leurs mots puis ce gars a fait de
l'ombre un plat tu remontes pour chaque
pas sa carrure par sa valeur personnelle
et c'est le jeu des peaux de banane même
de ses meilleurs amis qui pensent le jeu
des poules pas naïve on se sent soulagé
il a avalé beaucoup de couleuvres il a
vraiment franchement l'a vu souffrir et
c'est terminé
voilà maintenant il va pouvoir retrouver
sa liberté une liberté retrouvée dont on
se félicite également à l'hôtel de ville
où ses anciens collaborateurs qu'ont pu
estimer l'importance de sa décision je
crois qu'il faut de dire que philippe
seguin prend des décisions sur un coup
de colère
je crois que lui arrive de faim dans des
colères mais il lui arrive surtout quand
il prend une décision sur toute cette
importance je vois qu'elle est très
réfléchi je crois que le texte qu'il a
rédigée leproux ici personne ne doute de
son avenir politique
beaucoup se réjouissent de le revoir
plus souvent dans son bureau d'epinal et
voyons maintenant comment la base des
militants du rpr a accueilli la nouvelle
de la démission de philippe séguin pas
d'état d'âme mais une seule volonté
affichée apparemment continuer coûte que
coûte avec ou sans ces gars là campagne
pour les européennes comme le monde ce
reportage arras dans le pas-de-calais à
new york dominique maes journée presque
ordinaire dans cette permanence rpr
quelques militants nous sommes loin de
la fureur des états majors parisiens au
coeur des conversations leur prochaine
réunion de district sur les européennes
avec une feinte philippe seguin
la campagne continue on a lutté que
brosseau depuis 97 aujourd'hui ce qui
est présent avant tout à l'esprit des
militants c'est de continuer la campagne
et que peut-être aspects l'aspect du
chef et apparaît comme secondaire sous
le regard de leurs anciens chefs de file
les militants avoue pourtant surprise et
déception
il devait vraiment il y avait une
démission c'est entendu tout cas le guen
après les européennes mais pas de mode à
ce que tu as aussi important on est un
peu comme des orphelins aujourd'hui on
n'a plus de président pour ces orphelins
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est le
courrier envoyé aux adhérents
alors on n'a pas très envie de se livrer
au jeu des pronostics
qui va succéder à philippe seguin pour
les européennes on évoque juste une
liste d'union man et bien sûr par un
expert
quand on lit la presse et quand on
écoute la télé j'ai entendu parler de
monsieur sarkozy est le monsieur bernier
ben je me dis kim jong un et malgré les
gros titres des journaux
officiellement personne ne se montre
inquiet quant à l'avenir du parti le
coup est dur mais l'horaire perdre que
le sans réveiller et sans relever et on
peut assimiler le départ de philippe
seguin a la taille d'un arbre atteint
une taille de printemps une grosse
branche est tombée mais avaient fortifié
racing ici les militantes de ni
départ de leur chef de file un simple
faux pas pour le rpr avant de mieux
repartir
charles millon le président de la droite
a finalement renoncé à présenter une
liste aux élections européennes pour ne
pas ajouter dit-il à la cacophonie
charles millon qui estime que la
démission de philippe séguin devrait
déboucher sur un sursaut salutaire toute
une région se mobilisent pour défendre
l'emploi dix mille personnes dans les
rues de pau pour protester ce matin
contre le plan de suppressions d'emplois
chez elf françois bayrou président du
conseil général des pyrénées atlantiques
s'est joint à la manifestation
mobilisation réussie malgré le mauvais
temps
éric perrin à frédéric brun chèques des
commerçants qui font ville morte des
manifestants qui bravent un an de déluge
le béarn a réussi son pari mobilisé dix
mille personnes
l' annonce de la suppression de la
moitié des 2000 emplois de l papaux a
choqué et si les hommes politiques
toutes tendances confondues sont là
aujourd'hui c'est pour apporter leur
soutien tout en avouant une certaine
impuissance face à ce libéralisme
économique où les actionnaires passe
avant les salariés sommet intervenait
auprès de christian querré comme les
scans de tout le monde mais
c'est à dire c'est à dire que il faut
beaucoup de courage à l'heure actuelle
pour être un homme politique c'est à
dire qu'ils vous disent qu'ils peuvent
rien faire c'est enfin qu'ils peuvent
rien faire mais on sent que nous ne
sommes pas vraiment écouté et chacun
dans le cortège de s'étonner qu'une
société qui fait 8 milliards de francs
de bénéfices abandonne ainsi cette
région c'est toute l'économie locale qui
est concerné par ce coup de poignard qui
nous est donnée par une société qui est
née chez nous et qui est donc béarnaise
qui a des devoirs envers les berner le
dernier espoir des salariés d'elf c'est
cette mobilisation de masse de toute la
région pour essayer de faire fléchir des
finances et que nous avons chez nous qui
sont des assassins de l'emploi nous
avons besoin de trucs il n'ya pour
qu'une société qui ne veut ne pas tenir
compte de l'opinion publique et quand
elle s'exprime aussi fortement à cette
région je pense qu'il ya la possibilité
d'être entendu
alors qu'elle lançait une pétition la
grève tournante sur les sites de pau et
de la continue en attendant une
prochaine manifestation le président de
l' american express en france a été mise
en examen cette semaine dans l' affaire
d'escroquerie du sentier qui met en
cause plusieurs centaines de sociétés
qui auraient établi des circuits de
blanchiment
ce procès qui concerne 130 quatre
prévenus se tiendra prochainement joël
bruandet jusqu'à présent les banques se
disait pour la plupart victimes de cette
vaste escroquerie qui porte au total sur
près d'un milliard de francs
désormais un établissement la filiale
française de l'american express banque
est soupçonnée d'avoir facilité le
travail de certains escrocs et son
président a été mise en examen
tout commence en 1997 une dizaine de
banques alerte la justice sans porter
plainte sur une escroquerie pratiqué par
certains commerçants du sentier la
brigade financière enquêtent et en
quelques mois près de 150 personnes sont
interpellées
les enquêteurs découvrent alors que des
centaines de sociétés de confection sont
impliqués l'escroquerie repose sur un
système de traite fictive que
s'échangent entre elles les entreprises
d'e trade qui ne repose sur aucune
transaction réel mais qui permettent
d'afficher un bon bilan est donc de
convaincre les banques d'accorder des
prêts une fois le prêt obtenu
l'entreprise
disparaît l'argent lui est déjà parti à
l'étranger et c'est en suivant le
parcours de cet argent que les policiers
ont découvert le rôle de la banque
américaine dans un communiqué american
express reconnaît aujourd'hui avoir
traité des chèques effectué pour le
compte de banques correspondantes sur la
bande s'il ya blanchiment ce serait donc
à l'insu de l'établissement mais avec
cette mise en examen
la justice veut déterminer si american
express n'a pas cherché à aider certains
escrocs à blanchir leur butin à paris ce
tragique accident un adolescent de 17
ans est décédé cet après midi après
avoir reçu une balle dans la tête par un
de ses camarades qui s'étaient emparés
de larmes de services naples et c'est
christophe kulikowska presque 24 heures
après avoir été blessé par un camarade
de jeu un jeune footballeur de 17 ans
est décédé cet après midi à l'hôpital de
la pitié salpêtrière
hier soir aux alentours de 20 heures une
rencontre de football devait opposer
deux équipes de juniors de la région
parisienne
l'entraîneur d'une équipe est un
policier profitant d'un moment
d'inattention dans un vestiaire
l'un des jeunes joueurs fouille son sac
il subtilise son arme mais temps joue un
copain le coût par l'un des numéros ces
arbres lussier et du conte c'est quand
il s'est retourné vous donner les
maillots aux joueurs que le gamin il n'a
plus le
le revolver dans le sac et ça vous êtes
un pack un policier comme ça vient avec
une arme chargée dans son sac
normalement il aurait dû mettre sa
parole en bien moins enlevée à la portée
des gosses les policiers ont le droit de
garder leur armes quand ils sont en
repos de condition tout de même pas plus
de quarante-huit heures et larmes doit
être déchargée en l'état actuel de des
éléments que nous avons je peux pas
affirmer que l'armée était approvisionné
mais les c'est vrai que les textes
disent bien que l'homme les les baltes
en tête dans sept rapports l'auteur du
coup de feu est toujours en garde à vue
le brigadier de police propriétaire de
larmes a lui été remises en liberté
les départs en vacances pour la zone qui
inclut notamment la région parisienne
prudence sur les routes
hier soir dans l'orne deux accidents ont
fait sept morts la plupart sont des
jeunes dont un enfant de trois ans
d'abord une collision frontale entre
deux voitures l'autre accident s'est
produit sur la nationale 12 une voiture
a percuté un pylône électrique tennis
dans le premier tour de la fed cup qui
oppose la russie à la france amélie
mauresmo pour son premier tournoi balayé
elena lykov ceva 6 2 6 2 mais la grosse
déception de la journée vient de la
défaite de nathalie tauziat qui fait à
signer 6 4 6 2 face à tatjana à phaneuf
a pour l'instant la france et la russie
sont à égalité le festival de pâques de
deauville la troisième édition consacrée
à la musique de chambre festival qui
s'achève ce soir nicolas cornu langlois
bernie meuriot
depuis trois ans douville a réussi une
performance réunir des jeunes musiciens
solistes qui viennent jouer tous
ensemble sans vedettariat que tu me
courante aux états unis mais plutôt rare
en france
alors toute la semaine ya des
répétitions dans les lieux les plus
étonnants pour des répétitions puis ce
qu'il répète dans des bureaux il répète
dans des bars ils répètent dans la salle
où on vend les chevaux ils jouent de la
musique de tous les siècles de tous les
gens du baroque au contemporain et je
crois que ça aussi c'était bien l'image
de deauville au plaisir des concerts de
musique de chambre s'ajoute ainsi pour
les solistes l'excitation de répéter
ensemble une symphonie de heinz daube et
offre chaque année un chef d'orchestre
réputé bien fédérer tous ses talents
dans un orgasme phonique très rarement
j'obtiens faits de complicité cette
décontraction et cet enthousiasme
hélas ici à deauville avec cet orchestre
on a on a cette ferveur on a cette fois
on a cette ébullition
cette curiosité aussi
et sougou de de s'écouter de faire la
musique ensemble
renaud capuçon violoniste est l'un des
musiciens solistes fondateur du festival
et de la philharmonie de chambre de
paris
contrairement à tous les clichés qu'on a
sur les musiciens je pense qu'on est
bien sûr on peut en soliste ou un
musicien d'orchestre mais je pense qu'on
est avant tout un musicien et si on est
un musicien
on doit être capable de jouer dans un
orchestre capable de jouer un trio de
brahms est capable de jouer un concert
de prêteur en ce sens c'est une
expérience unique
un festival qui joue sur le renouveau
sur la musique de demain sans frontières
avant la 13e soirée des molières qui
sera retransmise sur notre chaîne le 3
mai prochain un déjeuner a réuni
aujourd'hui les nominés parmi eux
cristiana reali comme meilleure
comédienne niels arestrup robert hirsch
nominé comme comédienne l'année et puis
barbara schulz dans la pièce de jacques
attali ou tedjar depardieu et barbara
schulz nominé comme révélation
la soirée sera présentée par pirate
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres chassé du
kosovo des dizaines de milliers
d'albanais arrivées aux postes
frontières
selon le gouvernement britannique un
million de réfugiés ou de déplacés
depuis un mois la moitié aurait quitté
le kosovo
ces deux mc arriveront sens le premier
groupe de 308 réfléchir à pau dix mille
manifestants pour protester contre les
suppressions d'emplois chez elf une
région mobilisés aux côtés de ses élus
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinez 20h52 samedi soir chez estelle
1h20 le dernier journal lance du fera
demain 7h dans thé ou café catherine
ceylac que reçoit robin renucci midi
argent public présenté par sylvain attal
je vous retrouve demain dès 13 heures je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2
oh